[Music]
are you ready for the Royal way oh come
on I want to be a royal I remember that
Lord song alright it we're ready for
Meghan's big day yes yes it really is a
fairy tale come true for Meghan Markel
actually becomes a duchess but we knew
her when she was still just a commoner
so we're gonna leave you tonight with
some of our favorite and best Megan
Markel moments hi everybody this is my
last straw and then get some sleep and
then do it all again tomorrow and then
trust your team to transition you into
Cinderella for the night I think the
world is changing in a way that's being
on a runway or in casting like TV film
anything like that but it's getting to a
point where as it should be a bit more
colorblind
we'll just run up and hug us yeah you
know say we inspired them to dress up
for work
Oh snarl is good wait hold on you have
one little dot on your nose it was just
water I think you know or that 19-hour
day you Megan selfie okay one two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]